let's go to the phones which are
exploding today at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50 and
see what's on people's minds starting
today with our caller from the 4 for 3
area code caller from 4 for 3 what's
your name where are you calling from
this is Anthony calling from Maryland
alright Andy we've got you sounds like
you have gremlins in your phone but go
ahead
thank you for listening a video titled
fascism is secretly a left-wing ideology
he said that fascism means he said that
left-wing mean let more government and
right-wing means less government that
fascism is left-wing by that definition
and anarchism is right-wing would you
agree with that was sort of that
description of the political no I would
more versus less government is very
different than saying more or less a
libertarian for example what matters is
what government is doing what matters is
how his government interacting with
people and government doing things is
not fascism but Anthony I'm gonna let
you go because your connection is is so
bad it's just a very very strange noise
that's there and hopefully it's not
another one of those embarrassing
instances where the problem is on our
end
we'll find out with our next caller
let's go to our caller from the 7:07
area code caller from 7:07 what's your
name and where are you calling from
hi David this is Bart and I'm calling
from San Francisco hey Bart what's going
on your connection is pristine I must
say oh I'm I'm glad yes a question for
you is did you figure out your YouTube
issues with the algorithm I know you
were having issues with with that and I
emailed you a while back about that I
was just wondering if you had what the
status was a bit well I don't I don't
know which element of that you're
referring to because the the YouTube
algorithm is sort of like a lobster
regularly shedding and molting and
having a new shell and it's a constant
new series of issues but certainly so
YouTube has whitelisted us for
coronavirus monetization so that issue
has been solved but there's always
issues you know we that there's search
issues there's other issues so I don't
know exactly which issue you're
referring to right now the biggest issue
is oh it was the money it was the
monetization sorry it was the
monetization I was just say there are
people like me out there are tech people
out there I think that can help you but
just in case you're interested we you
know there's people in the follow use I
think it could be helpful okay well we
never really eat it's and advice are
welcome but right now I mean the big
thing now is because of the virus and
fewer advertisers you're wanting to
advertise CPMs or how much you make for
every thousand views are down about 3035
percent that's not that's more of a
systemic issue than an algorithmic issue
unfortunately gotcha
then move on other callers my next
question is what could we do to help the
never Biden folks you mentioned that are
saying never Biden and so on and who are
the leaders of that movement how can we
help you know convince them to go down a
better road at least get through this
transition point the leaders question is
an interesting one I don't know who
leads the never Biden movement that's I
mean it's again I think that in the same
way that support for Bernie was
overstated if you just looked at Twitter
and reddit the size of the never Biden
movement may be overstated if you're
paying too much attention to Twitter and
reddit I think it's a smaller movement
than maybe people on the internet think
but I don't know that there are
necessarily leaders to convince I'm not
sure I don't know if there are mean like
are there prominent never Biden people
I'm asking genuinely I don't know I
don't know I just listened to your
comments about that it helped how
they're you're mentioning that there's a
movement I was just trying to figure out
ways that we could help convince that
movement where to go on Twitter or
wherever you know to talk to people and
to help need to help them yeah what's
been the only thing that's been at all
effective and they're proud that there
are probably more effective things is to
really drill down on okay so who do you
want picking the next Supreme Court
justice whose policy do you prefer on
the environment whose policy do you
prefer on taxes and
usually with most of that I mean listen
if they actually preferred Trump's
policies than they should be voting for
Trump and there's not much to argue
about but usually people will realize oh
I prefer Biden's policy on everything
why would I do anything that helps Trump
get reelected it's counter it's
counterintuitive doesn't make sense yeah
makes sense like absolutely last
question and why can't reporters do
real-time debating with with trim so
what's the what's the real issues it's
just access and what's your take on that
and how do we convince them to be a
little more forthcoming yet silences
them he moves on he controls the bully
pulpit and it's it's hard to insist on a
debate with Trump in the press briefings
although I also wonder what the outcome
would be I think it would just turn one
lie into four that now you're trying to
fight so we've talked about that for I
don't know thanks Bart really appreciate
the phone call hope to hear from you
again